yeah hi I'm James I'm here to talk to
you about breaking changes to provide a
bit of context and introduce myself I am
the creative and maintainer of among
other things this set of NPM packages
that provide WebSocket messaging like
various layers of that protocol they're
quite widely used by a lot of different
projects they generate about 8 million
downloads a week between them and I've
been maintaining these pretty much since
node was released so since early 2010 so
this is a reflection of my experience as
an open-source maintainer of seeing
thing to change over time and what the
effects of that are an additional bit of
context this talk should not be
construed as a complaint about how
things work we should be really grateful
for all the software that we get like
for free that lets us do loads of
amazing stuff I'm more trying to reflect
on again like my own experience rather
than like bashing anybody else and
saying you're doing this wrong it's more
like how can we reflect and and improve
what we don't okay so with that out of
the way what do we mean by breaking or
consider this module at the top that has
a method called get and it takes a URL
and it makes an HTTP request that URL
and then it invokes your callback with
an object containing the status code
which I've hard coded here as a number
now let's say that we changed that
number 404 and replace it with the
string the 404 do we think that's a
breaking change or not well to answer
that we have to look at some use cases
so if something is calling this function
and it's using the weaker quality
operator to compare the numbers that
will keep working because in JavaScript
a number is weakly equal to a string
representation however if we're using
stricter quality this code will now
break because numbers and strings are
never strictly equal to each other so if
we have this code we consider the change
to the HTTP module to have broke on our
program there's another example this
module contains a message that takes the
name of the table and it runs a query to
count the number of records in that
table
and then it invokes your call back with
the count which again I've hard coded
now notice something about this module
this is structurally identical to the
other module that I just showed you all
I've done is replace some of the names
the actual programmatic structure in
terms of what the compiler cares about
is exactly the same as the HTTP module
so if we believe that breaking changes
and compatibility is purely a function
of the source code itself then we have
to give the same answer for the HTTP
module and this one so let's look at
some use cases so say somebody is
counting the number of records in two
tables and then subtracting them for
example to work out the number of
remaining tickets left for a conference
now in JavaScript the subtraction
operator coerces strings to numbers so
then you get arithmetic subtraction and
you still get the same result as we you
were getting before but if you're adding
the two counts together the JavaScript
plus operator has an overloaded meaning
it performs arithmetic addition of
numbers but it also concatenate strings
together so if something that was
previously a number is now a string we
get like the the string concatenation of
those two values so this program no
longer does the same thing and the
author of this program would consider it
broken by the change that we've made so
yeah we would have to make an explicit
change here to account for the fact that
the database module has changed how it
represents the results to us by
explicitly converting the strings back
to numbers again so what we've seen here
is that the meaning of values and
programs is not like fully contained
within themselves and it's not to do
with just what their type is like a
number can be used first several
different purposes it depends how you're
using it that determines whether
changing it would be a problem and so
what we've seen is that rather than just
being a number like something having one
type it actually has a set of
characteristic traits and a Java
programmer might call these interfaces
Haskell users might call them type
classes but the core idea is that a
value of a certain type can be used for
several different kinds of operations
and it's which of those operations that
you're using that determine its true
meaning
so we've seen a couple of these already
like a number might be used for its
identity like an HTTP status code is not
really like an arithmetic number it's
just a machine readable label for
something but numbers also have
arithmetic properties you might want to
do maths with them addition and
subtraction and so on so that's a little
bit of an examination of like the
complexity that even exists in very
simple values like numbers
what about objects what happens when we
change the interfaces to those so let's
say we have a function that returns an
object that contains some information
about a talk at a conference in fact
this talk at this conference it contains
a title a date and a presenter all of
which are strings now adding a new field
to this object it's probably not a
problem any program that's using this
will probably just ignore the fact that
the new field exists right it won't be
relying on it so the the subject gaining
a new field won't disrupt any existing
code however if we remove a field like
the title object so the title property
some code that's using this function
will now probably break so for example
if we're calling get talk info and then
putting the title attribute of the
result into a string will now get a
string containing undefined and this is
a case where JavaScript doesn't alert
you to the fact that it's made a mistake
you don't get an error if you access an
attribute that doesn't exist you just
get the value undefined and that shows
up in the string so the program is not
broken in the sense that it's crashing
but it is clearly not doing what was
intended a user will notice that
something weird has happened here
likewise changing the types of existing
fields is likely to break existing
programs so for example if we would call
and get talk info and then splitting the
date field on dashes to break the date
into its component parts that will no
longer work because a date object
doesn't have a split method
so in broad terms adding new fields to
an object is fine the existing callers
will just ignore that new field removing
a field might break things as we've seen
and JavaScript won't alert you to that
problem and changing the type of
existing fields can also break things
and sometimes you'll get an error
because you're using a method that
doesn't exist but sometimes the program
will silently do the wrong thing but
it's not quite as simple as that and
JavaScript being a small language has
overloaded the few abstractions that it
has with several different meanings
there are multiple different ideas and
computation that are overloaded onto the
same thing in JavaScript and one of
those things is object we use objects to
represent the computational idea of maps
of records of object object-oriented
programming style objects and several
other things so what do these terms mean
like we're using this one thing object
for a lot of different functions we need
to think about like the different ways
in which it's used so map is an
open-ended collection of key value pairs
and typically the the program doesn't
care about what specific keys are in the
object it's just data and it gets
processed like whatever that is there
gets processed so typically if your
program is just iterating over an object
and processing whatever it contains
using the object as a map a record is a
value with a fixed set of known fields
where the fields can have different
types and the program usually cares
about specific fields within an object
so the props you pass to a react
component or a good example of this you
don't just iterate over them and do the
same thing with all the fields you'll
usually pick out specific fields and put
them in specific places in your UI an
object-oriented programming kind of
object is a bit like an extension of a
record
it's a computational value that combines
state with behavior so it's like a
record where some of the fields are
functions that access the records are
the data fields so the the image value
that I used in the previous example here
is a good example of that that image URL
bit comes from a class that takes a name
and it has a method that knows how to
calculate the URL for a particular size
of an
typically adding new methods to an Opie
style object is fine that's what enables
polymorphism that's what means that one
function can work with lots of different
kinds of objects as long as they all
have a method in common iterables in
JavaScript is a good example of that and
that's where a lot of the power of our P
comes from but adding new fields to
other kinds of things like records can
cause problems so for example if you add
a field to your web pack config that web
pack doesn't recognize you'll get an
error it doesn't ignore this key that it
doesn't know actually checks everything
your object includes and if it doesn't
recognize any of it you get an error and
it's doing that because in the kind of
program that web pack is it's usually
indicates an error on the part of the
user if it includes data that shouldn't
be there a usually indicates a typo or a
field that's no longer supported if
you've upgraded from three to four so
it's not always the case that adding new
fields to something keeps your program
working in some cases it will break them
and that's done for economic reasons to
help the user use the program correctly
likewise if you're intersecting
something into a database if you try and
save an object to it to a table and that
table doesn't have a column for one of
the properties your object has like what
should you do should that be silently
ignored who's to say so like our arms
typically include explicit instructions
for like these properties get saved to
the database and these ones don't and
the user has to decide like which things
belong in which category so that's a
little bit about like we've seen how
primitive values like numbers can be
contained quite a lot of complexity and
likewise something like object can take
on a lot of different computational
meanings and so changing it has
different effects in different
circumstances but another another thing
that causes programs to break is that
just the concepts we're expressing are
too complicated
so one example of this was the recent
proposal to add the flatten method to
the array prototype and a lot of people
petitioned tc39 to not do this because
it would conflict with another
implementation that was already out in
the wild but why would this be a problem
well it's partly first sort of
logistical reasons and like tc39 is
responsible for the environment that
exists in the browser right so we're
developers don't have control over that
our code gets deployed into all these
browsers and it just has to deal with
whatever's there right it's not like one
of our dependencies where we get to
choose which version it is and I think
that's in the browser affects our code
runs and we don't have correct direct
control over it
so tc39 changing things in a way that
conflicts with our code that can cause
problems but why does that conflict even
exist in the first place right if it was
if we were talking about a fairly simple
function it's quite likely that tc39 s
definition would agree with the one the
community had already adopted and we
wouldn't have a problem but the thing
with the flatten method is that it's
extremely conceptually complicated
here's one potential implementation
although so we implement flatten by
reducing starting with an empty list and
concatenate again and the way the can
capital essentially combine any nested
arrays inside the outer array and
flatten the array to one level deep but
you might decide you want your array
flattened infinitely deep and this won't
do that or you might care about other
kinds of collections so like other
iterable values like strings should they
be flattened what about if your array
contains a set that contains an element
that's already present in the outer
array what's the effect of null what
does it mean to even combine all these
values there's a very broad set of
decisions to be made here about what
this what this function even means and
that means that there's a very broad
space of different different
implementations of it so if you put two
implementations of this function in the
same program they're likely to disagree
with each other and so one way that you
can avoid breaking things is to avoid
using functions that are this
complicated or thin if you have
something and you want to flatten it to
one level deep you probably want to use
flat map instead if you know your data
structure is nested arbitrarily deep you
might want to use the
Japan or an or an interpreter if you
don't know how deeply nested your data
structure is then you actually have a
deeper design problem that needs fixing
so there's yeah there's a lot of
complexity inherent in this method that
means that it's just hard to make it
interoperate we saw a similar thing with
the buffer constructor in node so that
was taking several different types of
values and giving different behavior
depending on the type and it was really
easy to pass a number instead of a
string and then get different behavior
and this caused security errors in some
WebSocket implementations where you
could make the server expose unsanitized
memory T so we fixed that by turning
into several different methods that made
it explicit like the user would make it
explicit what behavior they wanted
either they want a buffer that contains
the byte data for a string or they want
a buffer that is a fixed size of memory
and now you've made it unambiguous the
user is saying what they want so it's
not just about the return values that
our programs have and how things are
consuming them there's also an implicit
contract between any function and the
things it takes in terms of what what
properties that expects them to have so
take this contains function this takes a
list and a value and it returns a count
of the number of times that value
appears in the list it does that by
initially initializing a counter to zero
and then using a for of list to iterate
sorry a for of loop to iterate over the
list and incrementing the counter this
works fine with arrays as you'd expect
but because it uses a for of loop it
also works with any other kind of
iterable values so somebody's currently
using this with a set it will only
return 0 or 1 for a set because sets
only contain one instance of each value
but that's good enough to retain
truthiness to detect whether something
exists in the set or not so now say that
the author of the contains function
decides to change it their assumption is
that it's only being used with arrays so
they'll use array methods to change how
it works they'll now implement it using
the filter method to filter for values
equal to the input and then return the
length of the result so this continues
to work with arrays just fine
but now it blows up when you give it a
set because sets don't implement the
filter method we get a slightly
unobvious error here like the word
filter doesn't correspond to anything
the user has said here it's actually an
error being thrown by the internals but
the program is now rejecting an input
that it previously previously accepted
and that's because the author assumed
that people would only use it with one
kind of value but then if they never
made that explicit so we should also
consider side-effects when looking at
our programs so JavaScript being an
impaired and imperative language our
programs don't just call functions and
return values they also have side
effects so for example here's a function
that adds a dependency to your package
jason by reading the file pausing it
adding the dependency and then writing
it back to disk if we had a console dot
log line at the end of that cheese log
what's happened is that a breaking
change will it depend where it's being
used if this being if it's embedded
inside a program that is expected to
produce JSON output and piped right into
something else that processes it adding
this log line will make that program
fail likewise if you have an event
emitter you might decide to add a new
value to the data that is emitted with
an event and JavaScript lets you call
functions with more arguments and they
were expecting so this ought to be fine
right but turns out somebody's using a
very attic function to listen to that
and expects all the values emitted to be
at the same type and be processed in the
same way so I could go on with these
these sorts of examples all day but the
core theme here is that JavaScript
doesn't make it particularly easy for
you to write code that works today and
keeps working
it's very permissive it'll often run
code that you would expect to throw an
error when it does give you an over a
message it's often kind of unhelpful and
doesn't really identify which bed of the
program is incorrect and it has no way
of you telling the compiler how you
expect people to use your program so the
compiler can't tell you if you've
changed something that would break those
expectations right so enough complaining
what can we actually do about any of
these things
so one popular answer to this problem is
semantic versioning or sampler for short
which is that you format your version
numbers as three three separate numbers
we're incrementing the first one means
that you've made a backwards
incompatible change changing the second
one means that you've added a new
feature in a backwards compatible way
and changing the last number means that
you've made a bug-fix but as we've seen
compatibility doesn't just hinge on the
module itself it hinges on the context
in which the module is being used so
semver
has like conceptual limitations in that
sense but also some practical ones it's
quite hard to express fine-grained
information like you might have released
a breaking change but you haven't liked
all the functions that I happen to be
using from your package you're still
fine so I don't I can't tell it from the
version number whether it's safe to
upgrade and you can see this playing out
in the ecosystem in that a lot of the
time so I've seen breaking changes in
production it's they actually show up in
bug-fix releases so one example of this
was last year we had a denial of service
vulnerability and per message deflate
and the way this played out was that at
the end of 2016 the Zed Lib library
released version one point two point
nine which is first released in three
years which gives you some idea of the
resources available to maintain
something easily as as widely adopted as
said Lib and that contained a change
that meant previously valid
configuration values that are required
by the WebSocket compression protocol
were now illegal and it would throw
arrows on them in April the following
year no js' released four point eight
point two and six point ten point two
which bundled this version of Zed lib
and began breaking WebSocket servers in
August when we were preparing a new
release of the libraries that I maintain
we discovered this issue reported it to
the node project and miles from the node
project reported this issue to Zed live
where it remains open like this is a
this is not a necessarily of buggins I'd
live this is very much up for debate
it's a blizzard loads intention that
these values are not legal and you
shouldn't use them but they didn't know
that this would break stuff to do with
the WebSocket protocol so a month later
after we'd spent time like figuring out
all the possible solution
the fact that we'd have to deviate from
the spec to make the program stop
crashing and written everything up per
message deflate release the patch and
then a month month off of that nodejs
released versions four six and eight
that made a patch to those LED lit
bindings the sort of paper over the
problem so this gives you some idea of
like the time it takes for these changes
to propagate through the system and
everyone's working with imperfect
information and we have to figure out
what's going on and that takes time and
so when you're changing a system you
don't just have to look at the sort of
the meaning of the program like on its
own you have to think about the the
effect on the ecosystem of the community
for the information and that changed to
spread if you make too much change too
quickly you end up leaving everybody
behind and people don't end up upgrading
your software so another approach to
dealing with breaking change is to just
try and never break anything right which
sounds like a pretty extreme position
and I'm not sure any of us would ever
manage to quite live by this standard
but it is a constraint that people try
and live to like we saw Ryan yesterday
say it's my fault and I'm very sorry
unfortunately it's impossible to undo
now this is like the world that we live
in like too much stuff depends on our
code and we can't change it but is what
I try to live by in my software and
that's probably to do with the logistics
of how maintenance works so there's
there's two main reasons why I try to
work this way so the first is like I'm
not in direct contact with all of my
users if I want to change something it's
very hard for me to inform the large set
of people that are using this code that
I'm going to change it and they might
need to update something also most the
people that are running my code don't
even know that they're doing so and so
my packet that my modules are typically
embedded as transitive dependencies
inside other things that people are
using so there's two or three or four
levels of intermediaries between the end
user and my code so if I break something
there are several other authors and
projects that would have to paper over
that for the end user to see any benefit
from it but the other thing is that
because I do open source in my spare
time I don't have a sort of predictable
amount of bandwidth
fixing problems so it's much more
valuable to me to try and keep things
stable rather than to take the risk of
releasing stuff that might break things
and then have no visibility and when I
might be able to to deal with that later
so I take a similar approach to my
dependencies like I typically leave them
open-ended rather than like pinning them
with the carrot or the tilde operator
because I want users to have the same
thing I don't want me to be a bottleneck
on people being able to get upgrades of
the things that I'm depending on and I
am taking a risk here that these things
might not be stable but and that's
counted by other measures like I'm quite
conservative with the things that I
depend on I'll typically try and adopt
something and then live with it for a
few months to sort of see see how it
pans out and I get an understanding of
how it evolves over time before our
release its and my users so all this
hinges on communication all of this
stuff is we've seen a lot of talks at
this conference about how we communicate
with each other and the core message
that I want you to take away from this
is that compatibility isn't a sort of
objective like technocratic thing about
the code itself it's about the fact that
we all have input imperfect information
about like the author and the user and
the software know different things about
the software and that means that like
the author's intent and the users usage
will deviate so the best ways that we
can try to avoid things breaking is by
like affecting how people use our
software in how we communicate with them
we can partly do that through the code
that we write so javascript is still a
small language but it's growing a few
things recently to help you express
yourself a little bit better like it
might be more appropriate rather than
using a plain array to use asset that
might be help you be more specific about
your meaning instead of using a plain
old object it might be more appropriate
to use a map for the distinctions that
we saw earlier if if you want to think
about the operators and functions that
you're using if you know you're doing
string concatenation then rather than
using the plus operator which is
ambiguous consider using templates or
the join method that tell people that
you know you're doing strength
incarnation you can try and avoid
bristle idioms in the language that make
it likely you'll have to change your
mind later so for example if a program
is growing a long list of parameters
and it you keep adding more things to it
that both that makes the coolest of
those functions a bit cryptic like what
a true-and-false and zero mean I don't
really know and they also every every
time you add a new parameter it gets
more complicated a nicer way to do this
might be to use object destructuring and
therefore sort of simulating named
arguments with and you can easily give
them default values that makes the
function easier to change and it also
makes the caller clearer about what it's
doing a really good example of this is
callbacks if you want to add a new
parameter to a callback function that
parameter needs to go before the
callback and then you need to do some
sort of mending up at the top of your
method to account for callers that
aren't passing that new parameter yet
it's much easier to do this if your
function returns a promise because the
parameter list hasn't been polluted by
this extra parameter that needs to be at
the end so it's much easier to just add
a new parameter there with a default
value and not have to add any of that
extra stuff
think about your arrow design my errors
should be a way that help users write
code that works it should they shouldn't
be a scary thing they should be there to
help people program like things throwing
errors when you're making mistake is
good for you so for example rather than
that cryptic error that we saw later
about filter not existing when we passed
in a set we could put an assertion at
the top of our method that checks oh I
expect this to be used with an array if
you're not passing an array I'll give
you a method that tells you that's what
I expected so you can spot the bug in
this code it's probably not very obvious
so the bug is that bites has to be an
integer but not all numbers are
divisible by 8 so sometimes we'll pass a
fractional value here this code worked
fine until node 9 and it actually liked
the crypto library rounded the number
down but the program that was using this
it didn't matter too much because it was
actually asking for a lot more a lot
more random data than it really needed
so that number being rounded down
slightly wasn't a problem but then in
node turn we started getting an error
key Len is out of range so this error is
both slightly unhelpful like the errors
that the number is not an integer know
that it's out of range but it's also
crashing a program that previously
worked so when you're adding errors to a
library later in its life
think about should that error get to
crash all the programs that are
currently using it is there a better way
you could communicate that failure to
the user for example it's quite common
for people to dig around in the console
and look at the properties things have
to figure out how to use them one
convention that we have in JavaScript is
that if you're accessing a lot of things
with underscores there's a signal that
you're doing something private that they
also didn't intend for you to rely on
that's not something a language enforces
enforces for you but it's a way that you
can signal so the user like hey I didn't
mean feeder to use this and it'll
probably break later and the final thing
that we have to rely on is documentation
so documentation should help people use
the code in the way that you're intended
often people land on Google and even if
you have like have really good
documentation arriving at pros that
requires a lot of context will usually
give people more questions than they
arrived with like if I arrived at this
bit of documentation I might be going or
what's a driver object should the URL be
an object or a string how do I connect
this stuff together and it's really
helpful to just give people a
self-contained concrete example that
they can get running locally and once
they understand the basic concepts then
they're more ready to dive into your API
details and understand things in more
detail and finally we have testing so
testing is a huge topic but I cannot
possibly cover in like the minute they
have remaining but one thing that I
often see people advise with testing is
that you should test your dependencies
don't test third-party code and that's
actually a really good idea you can do
that because what it does is it
validates your assumptions and it tells
you when they're no longer true like I
could write a method like me as the user
of the contains function we saw earlier
I could write a test that says oh it
works with sets and then one day that
will when they also changes it that host
will stop working I'll get an error and
then I'll immediately know that the
reason half my application is failing is
because this one assumption that I had
in my dependency is no longer true so
what have we learnt
so I've led that compatibility is not
purely a function of the source code
we're looking at as determined by the
context in which it's used we've learned
that that context is constructed by how
people use your program something you
can you very often don't have any
control over and finally that you can
influence that context by how you
communicate with the users and how you
tell them how the software is supposed
to be used thank you very much
[Applause]